[Musique]
bonsoir les amis swagger patron jean
duhau
et qu'est ce que tu as nounours un
passeport veut vrai avec ma photo et le
voilà regardez à il est magnifique avec
un passeport pareil je peux voyager
partout
je suis sûr que cornichons n'en a pas
aussi bon
homme peu probante aux bobos hop hop
[Musique]
hop hop apolosi t'es bon
j'ai un passeport
un passeport qu'est ce que c'est que ça
l'un d'eux tout un papier inutile et
encombrant roman un papier inutile et
encombrant data on voit que vous voyagez
fort peu et rares chers nounours ne
faisons qu'un voyage et vendons nolen le
long des routes de pays en pays c'est
vrai mix on voyage beaucoup mon voyage
dans des roulottes en voyage pas comme
des passeports mais ma petite pépite à
c'est ça un passeport un petit niveau
qu'on te demande lorsque tu vas d'un
pays dans un autre et que tu pas ses
frontières et à l'intérieur se trouve
ton nom est à photographier et les
frontières c'est quoi nous montres ton
petit lait tout passe par tient les
frontières cornichons ce seul
difficile à expliquer c'est ce qui
sépare deux pays cornichons mais nous
nous voyagerons toujours par des chemins
qui n'ont pas de frontières et quand par
hasard je rencontre une je m'arrange
pour passer à côté
il est de ces photos on vit à l'heure
mais qu'est ce que tu écris la non
nounours boys 1 m 25 ils se sont trompés
supposant que ça
signe particulier un truffe noire et
brillante
oeil vif
ok mais tu trouves et après ce sont
toutes des pages blanches évidemment
puisqu'il est neuf vraiment on dirait
que vous n'avez jamais vu de passeport
mais n'est jamais vide c'est un comble
voyager son passeport
sintas luxe inutile chers amis je n'en
ai jamais eu besoin et je m'en passe
fort bien et que faites vous des
gendarmes les gendarmes nous connaissent
ils sont nos amis ce transfert ni
douille
ou passeport j'espère que vous n'avez
rien écrit dedans ou là bien décorée
tiens il fallait pas au long long mais
si c'est plus beau c'est ravissant
là
mon dieu que vont dire les gendarmes je
serais bien étonné que les gendarmes
vous courent après dans le ciel chers
amis j'espère on se trompe jamais alors
tes copains eh bien oui je remporte deux
jolis dessins de mes amis allons en
route de l'ours bonne nuit cornichons au
revoir à un ami d'anna
et toi juliette en soit sa main
que la nuit vous apporte calme et
tranquillité des foyers sans inquiétude
pour nous nous voyageons très bien sans
passeport au revoir camara
[Musique]
patron vous ne me croirez pas ils ont ri
en voyant mon beau passeport ils
voyagent tous sans papiers même dada il
trouve ça inutile or son cheval il en
raison d'une eau
alors il est tard laissons les enfants
se coucher et disons-le heures à bientôt
a bientôt
sonné nuit fed pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
où
m
[Musique]